[Musique]
plus de fric à les écouter noble
fallières 3éme and organs home and funk
capanna miss teen dream and functional
d'ornano micheline dax
[Musique]
exposito
si un gant
[Musique]
et
autre vie à partir du 11 mai ce ne sera
pas exactement la vie d'avant le
confinement pas tout de suite et
probablement pas avant longtemps
comme nous avons appris à nous battre
contre le virus
nous allons apprendre progressivement à
organiser notre vie collective avec ce
virus en mettant en oeuvre de nouvelles
habitudes en vivant dans un quotidien
qui sera un peu différent mais en
retrouvant la liberté à laquelle nous
sommes attachés
[Musique]
we want to realize that is england nfl